thanks for the introduction uh great to
see all of you so yes i'll tell you
about some some of the things we've been
exploring think about how do we
make sure that the algorithms that we
deploy are responsible and uh you know
safe and reliable especially in
biomedical context right where these
algorithms can have quite sensitive
impact
um so just in the way of backgrounds
right so a lot of the things that we're
interested in here in my group at
stanford is actually in both in building
these algorithms and also in deploying
them both at stanford and elsewhere i
just will give you a couple of examples
um where we think you know the ai can
have really quite large impact in health
care so this is like one system that we
built um which is basically a computer
mission system for looking at these
cardiac ultrasound videos like the ones
shown here
so there are
many of these like millions of these are
routinely collected right and we
basically look at these videos the
algorithms try to assess various cardiac
conditions like heart diseases right
from these videos
so now the paper was published about a
couple years ago but now the last two
years we've actually been working quite
hard on deploying this in the emergency
department uh here's the setup that we
have at stanford
so another place where you know we think
ai can be really useful especially in
healthcare is in sort of telemedicine
applications
right so
as some of you might know especially
during the pandemic the telemedicine
actually really exploded
uh so for example at stanford
the number of televisions actually
increased by 50 fold compared to over
the last two years
right so the idea of telemedicine is
that instead of having the patient come
to the clinics right so you actually the
patient will interact with the physician
without having to leave their home
right
but one big challenge is that you know
how do you really ensure that the
doctors actually still get sufficient
information from the patient even though
even though they're not interacting with
the patients physically right you know
in person
so we developed this tool called true
image which is basically the idea is to
help
patients to take a really
high quality the clinically great images
so that they can send those images then
to the doctors right so the doctor can
make informed diagnosis
and judgment from the images even though
they're not seeing the patient in person
right and turns out that's you know one
big challenge is that even though all of
us are very good at taking photos for
instagram for facebook we're actually
very bad at taking photos that are
clinically useful right so this is where
we have an app that's being deployed now
um that's trying to make this much
easier for the patients to take high
quality photos
um another place where we're really
actually deploying the algorithms is in
improving clinical trials
right so clinical trials sort of like
the big bottleneck that's the most
expensive stage of all of medicine
so we built this tool
basically to help people to design
clinical trials to make it more
efficient and also make clinical trials
more diverse and more inclusive
so this is now being used by roche which
is the largest pharma company in the
world to help design some of their new
cancer trials
so a lot of our interests along these
lines is really in taking these
algorithms right
that we develop
a lot of research and actually really
into practice into deployment because
that's where we have some of the biggest
impacts
right um so to motivate the rest of the
presentation i want to tell you about
you know some of the really interesting
challenges that we run into when we
think about actually deploying these
tools
and then this then leads into some of
the more interesting sort of machine
learning ai questions that i'll talk
about in the second half
so just to give you a concrete example
right um so i mentioned dermatology
whereas dermatology is actually one
place where there's currently been some
of the largest investments in ai for
healthcare
and the reason is that like dermatology
kinds of data is relatively easy to
collect right so if anyone obviously was
the phone can take the kind of images
like this right on your phone
and then the kinds of algorithms are
basically you know running
various components under the scene and
trying to diagnose like is this likely
to be skin cancer or not
right so in this case unfortunately this
is diagnosed if you like to be skin
cancer and then you should go visit the
dermatologist as soon as
possible right so the compelling the
reason why dermatology is very
compelling for ai is because first like
the data is readily accessible
right and the second is that things like
skin cancer
it's actually very treatable if you
catch it early on but if you catch it
too late then it's deadly right and
there's millions of people around the
world every year who
unfortunately have skin cancer but are
not diagnosed until it's too late
so so that's very attractive for a place
to deploy ai right so it actually took
the three of the state-of-the-art ai
systems including some developed by
commercial vendors
um and we wanted to sort our pilot them
and test them here to see can we
actually use them for stanford patients
right
so we took these algorithms so they will
have like very good performance um
like if for example if you look at the
original papers or the original studies
of these algorithms like there are auc's
that will be above 0.9
right so the first thing that we do is
okay so we just take these algorithms
out of the box and then apply them to
like real stanford patients
right
and then the performance is actually
really poor
right so the auc actually dropped from
point nine to a point six it's not
uh and just to be clear right these are
just
real
images right from real patients at
stanford there's no
perturbations no adversarial attacks to
these images
so this is actually like a really big
challenge right so the first question
right is like okay so what
happened here so how do we understand
why does the algorithms drop off so much
and then second how do we mitigate this
going forward
right so
i so we did a
systematic audit to explain actually
what happened to these algorithms but
before i tell you what happened
do people have any guesses um like what
why do you think the algorithms
performance dropped off so much when
they applied
when they were applied to stanford
patients
yeah um i have two thoughts in mind one
could be just the
there's differences in the instrument
that's being used to capture the image
or it's just the patients are different
in terms of like maybe the stanford
patient who has like
higher ratio diversity than the
patient group that was used to actually
develop the model or something like that
okay so there could be some differences
maybe either in the types of phones that
were used or in
the patient populations these are good
ideas yes did you have a oh no okay
other guesses
other
ideas you think those would
explain most of the difference or or do
you think there are other factors
maybe the way that the way that the
images were captured like the technique
that was used okay yeah so maybe even if
they're using the same equipment like
how they were taking it okay
so there's actually
a really big one that's missing
or a few big ones
what do people think yeah maybe they
were just not honest about their data
set like maybe they like trained on guys
or something
okay so maybe there are some issues in
the original results that were reported
so that's interesting
okay yes these are all very good ideas
so okay so we did actually an audit this
is like a detective story right so you
know when you figure out what actually
happened here
um no so we actually did a careful study
right um so
and again like the goal of this
detective story is that we're gonna
figure out like what actually
led to this
big drop off right from the point nine
to point six
right so can we understand actually what
led to those mistakes
so it turned out actually the first
um
maybe the biggest reason right what
there's actually quite a huge drop-off
in the performance was that there were
issues in the original test data sets
right um
more specifically right so the original
test data sets for these algorithms so
how were they collected so it came from
having
you have these images then you have
dermatologists as you look at each image
and say is this skin cancer or not skin
cancer
right so from visual inspections by
dermatologists which is reasonable
because it's easy to collect quickly
but you can imagine even having
experienced dermatologists visually
looking at the image they also make
mistakes
right so the actual ground truth comes
from you know you actually take a biopsy
of this legion and then you do a
pathology test to save the skin cancer
or not and so that's actually the ground
truth that we have here at stanford from
the hospitals
so if you actually convert the actual
ground truth to what the original test
data so there were actually a lot of
label mistakes in the original test data
right so just miss annotations
right which is not something that we
typically think so much about when we
develop machine learning systems so we
typically assume that maybe the test
data
should be pretty good
right um but in actually in a lot of
these real world applications like the
test data even the labels can have a lot
of biases and mistakes right so in this
case actually explains
quite a big drop of the model
so the second big factor which maybe
accounts for about a third of the models
drop off which something i think people
here mention is that there's also a
distribution in type of patients
right so it turns out that in the
original data sets that are used to
evaluate these algorithms they are
mostly common skin cancers right again
easy to collect data
here at stanford we have both common and
also less common diseases people come to
the hospitals for a variety of reasons
right and the models did worse on these
less common diseases right that does
also contribute to some of the drop off
so the third one um is that actually it
turned out that
the algorithms um were quite poor
when applied to images taken from
dark skinned patients
right so for example especially if you
look at how sensitive the algorithms are
in detecting skin cancer the sensitivity
here means that if the patient actually
has skin cancer this alcohol is going to
say that they have skin cancers right so
that's really important the sensitivity
is very low if the patient is uh has
dark skins
right and when we dug deeper into this
it turned out that actually the original
test data and also the training data
this had very few and in some cases like
zero image from dark skinned patients or
users
okay so i guess you know one big
takeaway lesson from this is that uh
when we think about actually deploying
machine learning in practice right so
often times just looking at to the
aggregate metrics like auc by itself is
really meaningless unless we really have
a context of what is actually the data
that goes behind this this uh no that
gave this metric right
and that motivates a lot of things that
i'll talk about later today is how do we
really
audit these data sets or how do we
provide that context and how do we
really understand why models make these
mistakes in a way that's sort of
systematic and you know
and comprehensive
any questions so far
okay
so the problem i think it's not just for
the dermatology
right so
you know in some other recent works we
actually
had uh done a similar kind of audits
of uh all of the algorithms that were
approved by the fda right all the
medical ai algorithms
uh so fda sort of like the sort of like
the gold standard the governing body of
one is a drug or vaccine or algorithms
in use on patients
right uh so there's a velocity there are
over 100 of medical ai systems
algorithms that were approved by the fda
to be used on patients
so each symbol here shows like one of
these algorithms
and you know i just stratified them by
which body part that they apply to
so we did like a similar kind of audit
for each of these algorithms so there's
a bunch of things maybe i just want to
let you just focus on two of the the
most salient kind of features one is the
color
right so i colored each of these
algorithms blue right if we actually had
reports of the evaluation performance
across multiple locations
right otherwise it's colored gray
so you know it's already visually pretty
clear that most of these systems right
so
over 90 of the 130
we did not actually find how well it
worked if
evaluation performance across multiple
locations across multiple hospitals
right so you only see how it works at
one location
and the second is that the only four of
these 130 were evaluated using more
prospective or like human in the loop
evaluation right so the remaining ones
were all evaluated retrospectively so
retrospectively here means that somebody
collected the data ahead of time right
so it's like a benchmark data set it
could be from the same hospital where
they were trained right and then they
just developed the algorithm and applied
that to that benchmark data set
right so that was the evidence that was
presented for the fda approval
right so as we saw from the dermatology
example right so if you're only if
that's the kinds of evaluations that
we're doing then that can potentially
mask a lot of potential limitations and
biases in these models right if you're
only evaluating it retrospectively at
one location
um you know so
we spell out some other things ai models
but we also look at
other
non-medical ai systems
right i know many of you have probably
played around with gpt type models or
these language models
um and
we also
do these kind of audits and they also
find that they also have
quite some different problems and biases
and mistakes right so here i just show
you like this sort of a video of one of
my students actually interacting with
gpt
uh so with how these models works you
can just type in a prompt right then the
rest of the
essay will be
where the paragraph will be
automatically generated by the algorithm
so we start with the prompt
the two muslims
right so the rest of this is generated
by the algorithm right now you can see
that give you a second to read but they
can say that so it's mostly talking
about like bombing and violence right so
this is just
immediately generated by the algorithm
so we can change the prompt
right
uh it would produce something that's a
different
output
but we'll still have very strong
violence associated a very violent
content
so my students you know abu i changed
other different problems about walking
to mosque
i generated a different story but very
violent still
and finally you know was fed up and then
he just wrote explicitly that they
walked in to worship peacefully
um but i guess the gpt was not really
deterred by that
and said that you know they walked in
but they were shot
for their faith right
um
so you can see that's like so these are
could be quite problematic if if these
are the
models that are used as
basis for
for digital applications like chat bots
or conversational systems
okay
and turn out this is actually quite
systematic for these kind of potential
biases right so we actually designed a
bunch of tests and probes to just see
okay so for different types of different
groups right they have muslims buddhists
atheists so how much of the content
generated by gpt
actually has surveillance associated
with it
right um and consistently right so maybe
so quite shockingly like over 60 percent
of the content generated by gpt
associate from these muslims actually
have some sort of notions of violence in
those content
okay
so
hopefully this example sort of motivates
the rest of the discussion which is uh
you know
given that we're trying to actually use
and deploy these systems right in
practice
um how do we really rigorously
evaluate and how do we monitor these ai
systems right i think that's really one
of the big challenges right it's the
shift the challenge is sort of shifting
from how to train and build these models
right which is what people have been
focusing on before too now if we
actually have these models and want to
use them in practice right how do you
then
make sure that they're responsible and
reliable and how do you really test them
right so that's really i think really a
really important area of open research
uh it's often challenged so especially
for
students here who are interested in new
research areas that are very impactful i
think this is really some of the the
biggest impact is uh
to be gained
um and today i'll tell you about some of
our thoughts in in these directions
um
most uh split into two parts one is on
the data side and that's more on the
model side all right for the data we
think about okay so how do we try to
audit these data sets in a way that's
sort of systematic
um
and then on the model side
there i'm really interested in trying to
understand using natural language right
like how
and why these models make specific
mistakes
let's pause and see if people have any
questions before i move on
do you know the gpt responses were like
memorized from the training set or
yeah it's a good question um
we don't think it's like exact
memorization
um
if they do like exact matching it's not
memorization but it could be that
there's
it's definitely quite reasonable that
there maybe there's some parts of the
training data that heavily influence the
model to make those
okay
okay so
data audits right um
first it's actually quite i found it
quite interesting just to see like what
data do people use
in these real world uh applications
all right so here we actually
looked at
just you know a particular application
domain which is this dermatology ai we
can and we have done sort of similar
kind of analysis for other application
domains i'll just show you this one
example since so far sort of our running
example here
right so here what we do is basically
actually look at all of the
dermatology ai models that were
published
right and then for each of those models
you can go to the papers and let's kind
of scrape and understand like what was
the data that's used to train those
models
so this is our summarizing of that right
um each square here corresponds to like
one of these models or one of the papers
right
and then the circles basically
corresponds to different data sets
right the size of the circle indicates
like how big the data set is
and then the circle is attached to
square if that's you know if that model
is trained or evaluated on that data set
and there are also two kind of colors
right so the red ones are basically
private data sets by privateers mean
that you know somebody actually credited
this data set but nobody else can
actually access it or
figure out what's in the data
right and then the blue ones are the
public ones that you know the public
benchmarks that people could use
all right so for example you see that
there's a couple of public data sets
like this one here that's used as pretty
common benchmarks across a lot of these
models
um but it's also quite interesting that
there's about like half of these models
like all these ones on top
that are
really
tested and trained on like pretty small
and non like private data sets
right okay and then no and the quality
of those data could also be quite
heterogeneous
right
and
so there could
and that limitation could potentially
lead to some of these issues that we saw
before
yes there's a lot of the diversity here
from um like different pathologies or
like looking at different diseases or
are they all looking at
similar diseases and just getting data
from
yeah it's a good question i think
actually
many of them many of these algorithms
are trying to predict pretty similar
diseases right so there's
the biggest one is like
a high level is a skin cancer or benign
and within skin cancer there's a
different
subcategories but most of them are
actually looking at pretty similar tasks
so despite the fact that they're working
on relatively similar tasks
there's very fractured landscape of what
data and
what and what heterogeneous sources of
data are used to eval to train these
models
when the data is private is it often
like proprietary to like a company an
industry or like a hospital or is it
just that researchers collected it on
their own and just didn't release it
yeah so some of these privatizations
could be proprietary to specific
companies um and there are others that
are also for priority that are collected
by academic groups but the academic
groups uh did not want to share the data
yeah so good questions
okay so in the face of now you have
these these different heterogeneous data
and hydrogenated sources of data right
so the
i guess the high level the mathematical
question we're interested in is okay how
can we come up with a
a holistic framework to audit these
different data sets
right and what do i mean by audits like
how do we even define that
so uh so here's what you know like the
definition that we proposed in terms of
how to audit these data right so if you
think about most of these machine
learning settings
right um ai applications where you
typically have your data that could come
from different sources right so each of
the symbols here could be maybe a data
from different hospital or different
type of type of patients
and you have your favorite learning
algorithm right where algorithm is
agnostic or you could be using neural
networks or xg boost your favorite
model
right and you have some deployments
performance that you care about right
which could be
again we're pretty flexible it could be
your
accuracy or f1 score or r squared if
you're doing regression right so you get
to pick whatever metric you care about
in deployment or revenue right
um
so when i say i want to have like a
fully
end-to-end data audit what i mean is
that okay by the model in deployment
achieves a certain level of performance
or maybe it's getting like 80 accuracy
right so i'd like to understand how did
the individual sources of the training
data
actually contribute to that 80 accuracy
right so that corresponds to
mathematically you know taking that 80
percent accuracy and attributing and
partitioning that back to the individual
data sources or the individual data
points
right and similarly if the model
actually exhibits make some mistakes or
how except some biases in deployment
right i would also like to understand
which sources or which data points
actually are responsible or contributing
to the model to make that
bias
right so i guess you know for the gpt
example i want to say okay so is this
particular type of sources of text right
from this particular newspaper that led
to the model to
the influence model to make this uh
violent associations with muslims
make sense
okay
so
okay so how do we think about doing this
right so maybe the
the first idea or natural idea that
comes to mind would be okay if i want to
figure out what is the
impact of a particular data point or
data source i mean the star one in the
middle
right
the
the simple thing is okay why do i just
see how much does my model's behavior
change if that data point is not present
right
so you know in statistics it's often
called like the level and outs or
leverage score kinds of analysis right
it's also called influence analysis of
the influence of individual data points
um
but the idea here is very simple you
just okay you think okay if i remove the
data points right
now i can trim my models all these data
points and see if it's decision boundary
but if i remove this data point i can
see the decision boundary changing right
i can quantify how much does that change
affect the model's performance right by
my
chosen metric of interest and then that
would be like the lever and out
score right or the value for that data
point
so so this is pretty widely used for
actually for for quite many decades and
one challenge with this is that we think
about using this for modern
machine learning applications when you
have quite large data sets right of
millions hundreds thousands of data
points then
it's just extremely noisy right if you
have like 100 000 data points right
the difference from this like one data
point is going to be extremely small
right because even if i remove it i
still have like a hundred thousand other
data points and my model has all sorts
of
intrinsic stochasticity because i'm
training with sgd and all these other
things
right so it's actually if i just do
leave one out then we're not going to
really get any signal to see which data
points are more important
um so
the idea that we proposed is to
so for an extension of this is this idea
called the data shaft scores
right um and the idea is quite intuitive
right so okay instead of doing this d1
out once right so let's actually do it a
bunch of different times across
different contexts right different
scenarios
so each scenario actually corresponds to
a different random subset of my data
right and i can see okay if i take a
model now if i take some random subsets
of my data then what is the impact of
adding or removing this particular data
point of interest from that subset
right
and
intuitively like the benefit from doing
this right is now that i'm actually
aggregating across many different
scenarios right the impact of this data
point which makes it much more
statistically robust right so it sort of
increases the signal to noise ratio and
because i'm looking at across these
different random subsets this also gives
me a way to estimate sort of disentangle
the different interactions between data
points
so we do this now across basically let's
leave one out across different scenarios
and then there's a particular way to
aggregate all of these scores together
across these different scenarios into a
single value that we call the data shaft
score for each data point
right and then since these are written
down in formula but basically what i
said in words you know it's the shaft
values or the weighted average of this
impact across different scenarios
so i'll just show you a few example
applications of how this actually works
in practice right so just going back to
our running example was this dermatology
example right so the training data as we
saw right could be very noisy it can
come from all these heterogeneous
sources and who knows
what how people collected them right
since here are some the actual examples
from the real data sets right so it's
very noisy
and then the shaft score actually just
computes a score right for individual
data points
right it's a number
so the score could be negative
and that suggests that that
image is could be misannotated or it's
contributing to some sort of noise or
bias in the model when it's being
deployed if the model is trained on that
data point
score is positive right suggests that
now that image is actually informative
right and the model by training on that
image actually does better right
in in deployment
and then a simple thing that we can do
right is simply just to weight my data
sets by the shaftly scores
right so this and then just retrain the
model on this weighted data set so this
has the effect of encouraging the model
to pay more attention to data points
that we
think are more informative or more
diverse or cleaner data points right now
so down wait and remove the impact from
having all these noisy data points
right and if you do this then and right
so
this serve substantially improves the
model's performance in deployment and
the benefit of this is that now we
actually just didn't have to collect any
additional new data right so this is
actually the same architecture and the
same data set i had before but we're
just asking training the model on this
weighted version of the data sets rather
than
just treating every point in the uniform
way
and also interesting to know like what
are the data points that actually have
the negative sharply scores
right
so so we took actually one of these
large databases um it's basically a
database of chess x-rays
um and we computed this right so you can
as we when we computed this you found a
bunch of images that have negative
sharpie scores
well i actually took each of those image
and then gone back to have like a panel
of
three experienced radiologists have them
reassess each of these images the ones
that have negative scores
um and it turned out that when you
actually have people to really take a
closer
and careful look at those negative
valued
negative images
um a large number of them i think about
60 percent of the images were actually
misannotated
right so like the disease annotation
they were given is wrong
but in the original medical records
right and that's actually why if you
train the model on those images then
that can lead to all sorts of biases and
issues in deployment
right
and and so basically the shelvey scores
are quite effective in identifying these
mis-annotated data points
whereas if i just simply use like
default kinds of scores which is the
green line here then that's really no
better than just doing like a random
search through my data sets
yeah and we've also
showed that you can apply this set of
ideas as data sharply sports to other
applications right beyond medical
applications for example if you want to
have like
facial recognition systems
oftentimes because of biases and
training data they may not work very
well in deployment especially especially
on like less
well-represented um minorities
right the shafty score also computes
like a score for each of this image and
here the effect of
shafty scores to basically up upload
data from
the more diverse populations right that
are underrepresented in the training
data set but are useful in helping the
model perform well once used in practice
right so right here again just by simply
retraining the data on his weighted
sharply scored right that has the effect
of asking the model to pay more
attention to these more diverse data
points and then that also improves how
well it works in deployments
okay
so
so there's uh so hopefully that gives
you a sense of how people can use these
ideas in practice
right so there's actually a bunch of
still open challenges with these
chaplain scores um i have to discuss
that more afterward at the end so one
big challenge is still like how do you
efficiently compute these scores and so
some of the data sets where we apply
this to right they can be a hundred
thousand data points with big confidence
right so how do you compute this
efficiently
um now we have some partial
solutions to how to do this right so
based on multi-color sampling to compute
the sharpie scores and also in some
cases we're able to derive like analytic
approximations
to the shaky score as these are analytic
formulas that we know mathematically are
very close to the actual shafty score
but because they're analytic we can just
compute them almost instantaneously
so we can do this now for certain
classes of like regression and
classification models
so another big challenge of the japanese
score is that they're not
i mean they'll just give you a number
right but the number may not really
reflect the randomness in the data right
because the data often is sampled from
some distribution all right so to
address that we also introduce these new
ideas based on essentially like
statistical shapely values right which
sort of places these data sharpie scores
on firmware statistical footing right so
now actually the shaft square itself is
like a statistical object like a random
variable that we can estimate the mean
the bias the variance and we can
show that this also has much nicer
statistical properties
that accounts for
randomness in the data
okay so before i move on to the the
second part about how to audit the
models um i'll just pause here and see
people have any more questions
okay
so
for the first half we've mostly focused
on like auditing the data sets right
which is definitely very important uh
and this thing there's a complimentary
question of okay now you have a good
data set or you have models trained on
this right so how do we really
rigorously understand why the models
have certain behaviors
right and in particular as we saw like
in our dermatology example from the
beginning right we want to understand
it's interesting to understand why does
the model make specific mistakes
right and i find mistakes to be
particularly interesting right because
by looking at why things make mistakes
that's how you can get more direct
insights into what are the blind spots
of the models and what are potential
issues and biases and also gives us
insights on how we can
actionably like mitigate these issues
so i'll tell you about a couple of
approaches that we've been exploring
one is actually on sort of extensions of
these data sharply ideas into what we're
calling neuron shapely values
right so it turns out that you can
actually also compute
something that's very analogous to data
sharply scores but actually compute that
score for individual neurons right in
your neural network
right so
the output is very similar basically for
each individual neuron right it actually
computes a score and says that how
responsible is that neuron to a specific
mistake that the model makes
okay
and something actually quite interesting
happens here when we do this when you
compute this neuron chapter scores right
um
so
it turned out to be they're like
extremely sparse
right so by that i mean like say if i
have like a model that's trying to
predict you know computer vision models
trying to predict whether this is like a
active volcano or not right so the
network itself could be very large you
could have tens of thousands of
artificial neurons
but when i actually compute like which
of the neurons are really
responsible for the model's predictions
there ends up that there's only like a
handful of maybe 15 to 20 neurons that
are actually responsible
right and i know that there are only 15
and 20 of these because here if i just
sort of remove these 15 neurons these
are neurons that have the largest neuron
sharply scores right so the model's
performance basically drops this
disappears if i just remove 10 of these
neurons
right whereas if i just randomly remove
neurons from this trained model then you
know just sort of a drop in the bucket
and models performance doesn't really
change right so that's the red curve
right so you know when i do these
oblations i know that there's only like
a small handful of neurons that are
actually critical
right and we can quickly identify them
by using these neuron sharply scores
so this is actually quite
useful right because then
if i want to understand like what is the
model actually doing then i don't need
to look at all of these tens of
thousands of components and neurons and
different layers i just need to look at
these 15 things
right which is no i could even do in 15
minutes
so just to give you like a concrete
example of what this looks like for this
particular yeah yeah question
is then you're on chapter value
analogous to the data chapter value and
that like you have to train multiple
subsets of the neural network to
complete those scores or yeah it's a
good question so this one is actually
much faster in that we don't have to
retrain the model we can just you know
take one your one neural network that's
already trained it's after it's already
trained all the weights are fixed then
we can just
oblate the different neurons right by
oblate i just mean like set it to be
uh
to always output like the average value
right and then see how that affects the
predictions of the network
so this so the neural sharpie is
actually even faster than computing the
data shaft
yeah good question so okay so for this
particular model right so it turns out
that actually the
the two
most important neurons like the ones
with the two is the highest chapter
scores are sort of sitting in the middle
of the network
right like maybe like this is the
inception model so like
actually right in the middle of the
inception
um
so
as i'm showing you some
visualizations of what each of these
neurons
is looking for right so for the most
important neuron i'll show you here sort
of the three examples in the training
data sets that leads to the highest
activation for that neuron
okay so what do you think that neuron
is looking for
yeah
okay so we smoke
other ideas
yeah so it's basically yeah it's sort of
like looking for smoke and it's more
generally looking for like you know
white puffs right the white puff could
be like mashed potato it could be smoke
or fountain but sort of like you know
looking for these white puffs
right and then
for the second
most important neuron like the one was
the second highest neuron chapter score
we're also showing you
the three images that leads to the
highest activation
right
yeah what do you think
what do you think's looking for
yes against the sky
okay yeah so maybe something like green
looking triangle screen green mountains
was
sky in the background yeah
yeah
um
exactly sorry so you have this
models for the active kennels where this
basically has like a smoke effector
in one layer and then this like mountain
detector in the next layer and we know
that these two detectors are essentially
unique right because from our ablation
study if i just remove any one of them
right the model is not able to detect
any volcanoes
um so i guess the key
interesting finding here is that
actually a lot of these trained networks
right um after they're trained right
they actually have
a very sparse number of critical neurons
i.e neurons that are actually
responsible for the model's
behavior for models mistakes
and that's actually great because that
makes it relatively easy for us to
identify those neurons using the shapley
scores and to actually understand what's
going on in these models
um so one thing you might be interested
in is let's look at okay if you do this
across many different models for
different predictors like where are
these critical neurons right where do
they
uh
you know where do they live
um
people might have thought that's okay
maybe these critical neurons are either
near the beginning or maybe they're near
the end of the model right it could be
even the second to last layer so the
models actually make the final
classifications
and
actually interesting things that
actually a lot of these neurons are
lying in the middle right so they're not
quite at the end but they're some of
these intermediate layers where a lot of
these crit sparse number of the critical
neurons are
and we find them to be quite useful for
all sorts of interesting applications
especially for detecting spheres
correlations in the model
right just just to show you one example
of this like if you actually have a
model like
one of the themes trying to predict this
are actually like dumbbells right that's
one of the classes trying to predict
right there's this image there's a
dumbbell in them
um and then these two rows correspond to
like again like the the top two of the
most important neurons that are
responsible for dumbbell prediction
right and for each of those i should
show you like what are the images the
training data that led to activation for
those two neurons
all right so basically the top one uh
looks like it's basically looking for
more like the geometries the shapes
right
something that could look like a
dumbbell shape which could maybe even be
a trumpet or other things
but the second one is actually pretty
interesting right so it doesn't actually
have any dumbbell looking shapes in it
so what do you think that one is looking
for
yeah so it's really looking for like
sort of bare arms right
um
and so it turned out that's actually in
the training data right so there's a
spurious correlation and that's every
time there's a dumbbell there's actually
someone holding it right so then the
model actually learned that okay so
let's invest
a critical neurologist actually just
look for people's arms
right um
and
so that's basically what this this this
neuron is doing right and by looking at
this it's actually quite
easy for us to detect that this is could
be a a limitation where you know a
spirit's correlation that the models
picked up
and we can this also enables us to
rapidly
edit the model right to remove these
kind of spurious correlations if it's
one thing that we can do is if i just
find that there's oh there's this
particular neuron here that's
looking for these arms and it's a
spherous correlation
right the simplest thing i can do is
simply just
zero out that neuron
right um and i can do this without
having to retrain the model without
additional data
so we did some of these model editing
experiments um specifically to actually
for this facial recognition systems to
reduce their bias across different
uh
ethnic groups
right so basically the we're starting
off with the original model so each
curve here corresponds to the model's
performance across different sub
populations right for example like bf
could be like black female
reds here it's like white male right so
the model initially sees quite disparate
performance the original model has quite
the spirit performance accuracy across
different subpopulations
and then we can as we did like we apply
the neuron shaping scores defined okay
so which neurons are actually the most
responsible for that disparity
right so there's a small number of them
and then a very simple thing is i just
you know zero them out just remove them
uh you can see that actually has the
interesting effect of still keeping the
overall accuracy quite high
right if i remove these biased neurons
where the overall model's performance is
still very high across the majority
groups but actually also significantly
improves the model's performance for
these
minority groups right for example the
performance for the black females
actually starts to increase quite a bit
just by zeroing out some of these a few
of these biased neurons
again so this doesn't quite address the
root issue of the problem which is the
imbalance in the training data
but if you don't have time or resources
to get collected additional trading data
or even to retrain the model then this
is like a relatively
easy way to sort of patch the model in
real time
okay
so the last part i want to describe is
um is following up on this right so
it's a deeper way to understand why the
models actually makes specific mistakes
right i know
and it's based on quite recent work
where we try to basically provide like a
natural language explanation
of at the high level that so that it's
easy for us to understand of like why
does model actually make a specific
mistake
right let's uh so we call this sort of
conceptual explanations or conceptual
explainers of ai mistakes
right so you can think of this as like a
conceptual explainer as being like a
wrapper algorithm that can be wrapped
around
computer vision or
classification models right as the
original model makes certain mistakes
then our wrapper for this explainer
actually provides us like a natural
language explanation for why did the
model fail on that specific instance
and here's just an example the kinds of
explanations we can provide right so
let's say you have this image on top
which the true label here is zebra they
fit into some of these algorithms
they'll predict to be a crocodile
and the explanation that we can provide
is that like the reason why this is
predicted to be a crocodile rather than
zebra is because there's like too much
water in the image
right so in other words like if the
image actually had less water and maybe
more field and maybe more cows right
then the model actually would have
correctly put it to be deeper rather
than crocodile
so here's how this framework works
um and the more details are in the paper
but the high level is that we're trying
to basically provide like natural
language explanations right for why a
model
makes us mistakes on a specific input
right and we do this first by like
learning like a library of these natural
language concepts that corresponds to
the different more fine-grained visual
concepts that people might care about
right so here you can have like visual
concepts for water or for cows right but
we can in general we will actually
create a library of these concepts and
we can just learn that once and then
apply that to all sorts of different
applications
um and once we have those concepts like
for a given
input like maybe that zebra here in the
middle where the model is making a
mistake
right so then effectively we're looking
for is you know in this
space of concepts right
what concepts do i need to
increase or decrease
such that the model then would have
gotten the correct prediction
right um if i modify the image in that
in those ways so that's why it's kind of
more like a counterfactual approach
right so the model is making a mistake
on its current inputs right how would i
how should i
modify the input
in a minimal way so that the model would
have actually gotten the correct
prediction on this modified input
and system by solving a particular
optimization problem
using this library of the concepts
and then the output then would be the
following right so then it says that
okay so
uh
so the reason why the model made a
mistake on this particular input is
because there's too much water right so
the water because the water is the
concept that if i reduce water a little
bit from this image right then the model
keeping everything else the same then
the model would actually have corrected
predict this to be at zebra
so just applying this to our running
example of the dermatology applications
right so here you have like example four
example images where the models made
mistakes right so the correct labels on
top the model's prediction is in the
second row
and for each of these examples right the
explainer is able to provide like this
cons the high-level conceptual
explanation of why did the model make
that mistake
right so for the first example right so
explainer actually learned that it's
actually
directly because of the skin color
right if the skin color had been
not a stark then the model would
actually have predicted the correct
label rather than the incorrect disease
and then the second example the
explainer learned that the reason why
the model made the mistake here is
because the image blur right so if o
else being equal right if the image just
had been a little bit sharper then the
model would actually have predicted the
correct label on top
the third example the mistake here is
really due to
zoom right so
like the reason why they made the
mistakes because the image is too zoomed
out right if it had been zoomed in more
then actually had gotten the correct
prediction
and the reason why the model the
original classifier made a mistake
on the fourth example is because i guess
there's too much hair
so by looking at this it's actually
quite easy for us to understand what are
some potential limitations and blind
spots of the model essentially skin tone
image blur is quite important right zoom
and need to be important and the model
doesn't work well when there's hair in
it
right
um so this gives us a way to and the
explainers have an automated approach
right so you don't need to do provide
additional annotations to the explainer
but this gives us a way to you know
quickly assess like what are some
potential reasons why the models are
making those mistakes
right and in some of the new work we're
doing is now that we actually have this
right natural explanation understandings
of the mistakes we can actually go back
and just provide natural explanations to
really directly edit the model to fix
those mistakes right without having to
retrain the model
uh so i won't talk too much about this
just in in the interest of time
yeah so just to wrap up right i mean i
think especially we're thinking about
how to
use ai safely and responsibly in
practice
it's a lot of the challenge is
changing shifting right from the
challenge of building the model the
challenge of actually testing and
evaluating and monitoring the models
right and that's really i think where
the big open questions are that are
really important
um
you know here we talked about some of
the limitations and how a lot of the ai
systems are being evaluated before
they're being deployed especially in the
healthcare context because i think there
are definitely some strong limitations
there
um i think
you know
it's really important to understand
how the data contributes to this this
potential mistakes into the models right
so datashaft is one approach doing this
you can also use these related ideas of
neuron sharply for auditing the models
and then you know it's really
interesting to understand why the models
actually make
specific mistakes right because that can
give us insights into what are the blind
spots of these algorithms
okay so i'll just
wrap up here so all of these papers and
code that i mentioned are available
on our website
and share the references for these works
and also i want to thank again all of
the students in my group that
led the development of these interesting
tools
so i'll stop here and i'm happy to take
any more
additional questions
[Applause]
yeah observation from earlier about
dropping neurons uh seems really
profound um how does that like what sort
of models does that apply to that you've
looked at where you can you know drop a
large amount of models drop a large
amount of neurons and still
get similar results
yeah it's a good question so we mostly
applied that to more emission-based
models
um
and
i think it's really interesting to see
how this will work also for language
models uh so that's like the language
part is more ongoing works
can you talk a little bit more about
these uh like this bank of concepts uh
that you had in the last bit like how
are those defined and then how do you
actually like
get their embedding
what not
yeah that's a good question so
um
so for example the concepts that we used
here is actually collected on a
different data set right so the nice
thing is that we want to learn the
concept once
and then be able to apply them to a lot
of different applications
so for example to learn the concept for
zoom
right we actually just had a small
number of images um
that were labeled as like whether it's
zoomed in or zoomed out right maybe
about 50 images right and then
um
or for the concept of stripes right you
can we just have like 50 examples of
stripes which could be from a zebra or
from t-shirts or socks right or curtains
and then
we look at basically the embeddings of
those
50 examples of stripes versus some of
the negative sets right in the embedding
space and that they can tell us okay so
here's like a particular direction in
embedding space that corresponds to the
concept of stripe
and then there's another direction that
corresponds to concept of you know zoom
or a color or order
right um so basically to learn each of
the concepts we need to have like a
small number of annotated examples
uh which can be collected ahead of time
or from some other existing database we
often would use like imagenet
existing to learn those concepts and
once we learn them then we can apply
them to new data sets for new
applications like these dermatology
applications where we don't really have
ex explicit annotations about zoom or
hero
yeah yeah building off that answer um
have
are you excited by any techniques for uh
supervised constant learning
yeah yeah definitely um so i didn't
mention here so one of the other
algorithms we built is actually called
ace which is like automatic concepts
discovery which is basically a
supervised way to learn concepts
um another approach that i think are
very interesting is that basically use
these cross-modal models like clip to
learn concepts
right because um and one of my students
mert has actually done a lot of really
interesting experiments there because
like these cross model models they have
the image encoders and they also have
the text encoders right just from the
image encoder then we're going to see a
case um like for example if i want to
learn the concept of stripe i can
actually just ask clip
what what is what part of the embedding
space corresponds to the
the word stripes right
and then from that we can actually learn
what are the corresponding
image parts that correspond to stripes
right um so
so the short answer is i think these
cross
these multi-modal models like clip or
dali are actually could be a good way to
learn a lot of the visual concepts by
leveraging the language components
okay let's wrap it up there thank you